quand tu as fait après satisfaction ta
main elle est elle est comme ça tu
l'attends ou tu l'arranges l'autre ouais
fais attention à tes mains ce dimanche
matin l'entraînement est plus intense à
l'approche des championnats de France de
majorette de saint-cer l'école une
compétition organisée les dimanches 23
et 30 octobre au gymnase Gérard Philippe
le club local les saintsyriennes créé en
1968 espère décrocher à cette occasion
de nouvelles médailles et promouvoir
cette discipline originaire des
États-Unis encore méconnu du grand
public français le major c'est de la
danse du maniment de bâton et on fait un
peu de gym aussi donc tout ça c'est
rassemblé et bah on fait des danses tout
au long de l'année et on se présente à
des concours solo dio et 1ier mai donc
prier mai c'est Group et là c'est des
solo solo on fait une danse pour les
premières catégories c'est 2 minutes 30
pour les plus grandes c'est 3 30 pour
remporter la compétition les 58
majorettes du club é de 6 ans à 50 ans
tout une astuce faut être une bosseuse
après s'amuser sourire et c'est le
principal faut savoir danser faut savoir
faire des mouvements faut être assidu
déjà voilà faut s il y a du travail
personnel moi je pense qu'il faut
surtout s'amuser faut pas se prendre au
sérieux on leur met des petits thèmes
des accessoires qui s'allument qui
clignotent elles sont content pour les
championnats de France plus de 300
majorettes venues de toute la France
vont s'affronter à sin l'école pour
assister à l'événement le tarif est
compris entre 2,50 € et 5
[Musique]
€ non je ne ple
pas
voilà oui je suis
là